[Musik]
hervorgegangen aus der vision eines
einzelnen mannes oridion ist das
internationale komitee vom roten kreuz
heute die größte humanitäre organisation
weltweit am hauptsitz stehen die opfer
bewaffneter gewalt im zentrum im büro
des präsidenten brennt licht peter
maurer bis zurück aus dem kongo seit
sommer 2012 arbeitet er hier seine
familie lebt in bern in genf ist maurer
wochenaufenthalter wenig schlaf dann
kann eigentlich jeder wissen wie die der
ideal weit beschäftigen dabei es
entspricht dem landläufigen sinn
vorarbeit es ist einfach das was ich
mache
in der vorhergehenden folge bringt peter
maurer im kongo die kinder ins
bewusstsein die der krieg zu waisen
gemacht hat
in lodz putins orthopädie zentrum
bekommt ein patient eine neue prothese
und neue möglichkeiten im leben
[Musik]
ist der familie auslöser ist in israel
angekommen und hat ihr erstes
erfolgserlebnis als delegierte
abraham trifft in kolumbiens dschungel
rebellen und ruft sie auf die
zivilbevölkerung zu respektieren
[Musik]
eine sitzung von vielen mit am tisch die
stabschefin und der generaldirektor
ich habe das papier der direktion über
das von den gelesen mit yves daccord der
weltweiten nummer zwei der organisation
ist maurer in engem kontakt
der ehemalige journalist ist für die
umsetzung der strategie verantwortlich
am hauptsitz arbeiten 900 angestellte
der weltweit 13.000 die stimmung hier
ist locker mal ist perdu
maurer ist jetzt manager der
menschlichkeit sozusagen
vorher war er botschafter bei der uno in
new york und staatssekretär im außen dem
parlament noch geht alles den gewohnten
gang
nichts weist darauf hin dass der tag
eine dramatische wende nehmen wird
[Musik]
wir sind in kabul seit drei jahrzehnten
ist das land mit krieg und bitterer
armut konfrontiert
im orthopädie zentrum hat direktor natur
den besuch eines ehemaligen patienten
amanullah verkauf telefonkarten als
starthilfe dient ihm ein mikrokredit vom
ikk diesen musste er innerhalb von 18
monaten zurückzahlen
putin will in kabul ehemalige patienten
treffen die lage außerhalb des
orthopädie zentrums ist angespannt alle
paar tage gibt es anschläge oder
gewaltausbrüche mit dem rückzug der
internationalen truppen spitzt sich die
situation noch zu
aus sicherheitsgründen muss jede fahrt
der zentrale gemeldet werden
viele menschen leben inzwischen in kabul
und das leben ist in jeglicher hinsicht
nicht einfach menschen kommen je um
arbeit zu finden
aber das ist schwierig sogar hier in
kabul
die menschen hier kämpfen mit vielen
problemen
[Musik]
noch einmal besuchen wir das heim don
bosco in goma mit 3000 kindern viele
sind kriegswaisen viele hiv positiv die
ikk mitarbeiterin beatrice reimann und
die delegierten rita palombo führen
familien die der krieg auseinander
gerissen hat wieder zusammen lustigen
lebt seit fünf monaten hier in seinem
heimatdorf in rohren da wurde gekämpft
auf der flucht verlor er seine familie
ich hatte angst hatte kein geld
das ikrk hat mir das leben gerettet
ich bin geflohen viele wurden getötet
gott hat mich beschützt darum bin ich am
leben
er kann uns nicht wirklich hinweise
geben die uns bei der suche nach seiner
familie weiter helfen
er hat aber eingewilligt dass wir ein
foto von ihm machen mit auch übers radio
suchen können
wir werden also seine fotos überall
aufhängen und vielleicht wird ihm jemand
erkennen
wie gut danke
die italienerin rita palombo betreut die
zusammenführungen daraus machen wir ein
plakat und wenn deine mutter
das sieht dann weiß sie wo du bist und
wie sie dich findet release ihrer
telefoniert zum ersten mal in seinem
leben
er spricht mit seinem vater der mitten
im kriegsgebiet in kuba lebt zu ihm
gehen kann er nicht das ist zu
gefährlich
er hat mit seinem vater gesprochen und
gesagt es gehe ihm gut und er sei gesund
aber das ikk könne ihn momentan nicht zu
ihm bringen da die situation dort noch
viel zu gefährlich sein
dann habe der vater gesagt aber ich bin
doch auch hier wieso kannst du nicht
kommen
der vater will natürlich seinem sohn bei
sich haben ungeachtet der situation dort
darum ist er jetzt hin und her gerissen
felicia weiß dass das dorf bombardiert
wird
er hat angst wir haben um die 20 kinder
deren familien wird zwar ausfindig
gemacht haben die wir aber momentan aus
sicherheitsgründen nicht zurückbringen
können
es ist unmöglich dorthin zu gelangen zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt können wir dafür
sorgen dass der kontakt zu den familien
sichergestellt ist
die kinder dürfen sie anrufen
zusammen mit dem lokalen roten kreuz
organisieren wir dass sie jede woche
telefonieren können
aber natürlich wollen die kinder zur
familie zurück
hier bleiben zu müssen ist schwierig für
sie beatrice ist ursprünglich lehrerin
seit zwei jahren arbeitet sie für das
ikrk
sie sorgt sie machen nicht einfach einen
job sie lebe für diese kinder
[Musik]
all diese kinder hier für sie bin ich
mutter erzieherin und verbindungsperson
zum ikk das ist meine welt
sie machen nicht glücklich sie kommen
zuallererst
[Musik]
so kommt sie ja
dort schlug ihn führt uns in kabul zu
einer ehemaligen patientin
[Musik]
auch sie erhielt einen mikrokredit
saralisa da hat beide beine verloren
heute besitzt die 19 jährige eine
schneiderei ich lernte beim ki ka ein
jahr lang schneiderin drei vier monate
lang war ich zu hause dann übernahm ich
diesen laden
damals hatte ich nur diese eine
nähmaschine zu beginn hatte ich nur
wenige kunden
ich und meine familie stellten alle
unsere kleider und tücher aus damit die
leute dachten wir hätten viele
bestellungen
ich hängte einen vorhang auf damit
niemand sah dass wir keine arbeit hatten
dann bekam ich einen kredit es lief
besser und ich kaufte mehr maschinen
afghanische frauen spüren bis heute die
schotten des taliban regimes
noch immer gibt es zwangsheiraten frauen
sind gewalt ausgesetzt und der zugang
zur bildung bleibt ihnen zumeist
verriert eigenes geld zu verdienen macht
sie unabhängig
ich möchte viel lernen und mehr und
meine familie kleider nähen
wenn ich das selber machen kann sparen
ich möchte so gut gehen können wie die
chefin fasan dann kann ich auch etwas
geld verdienen
die wirtschaftslage in afghanistan ist
sehr schlecht
mit dem einkommen kann ich meine familie
unterstützen
in afghanistan ist jeder zweite nicht
behinderte arbeitslose menschen mit
handicap sind fast chancenlos
[Musik]
behinderungen schaffen in unserer kultur
für alle probleme aber vor allem für die
frauen ist es extrem schwierig heiraten
ist für sie kompliziert einen partner zu
finden ist eines der ganz großen
probleme behinderter frauen ein eigenes
geschäft zu führen macht frauen
selbstbewusst
auch wenn ich nicht mein eigenes
hochzeitskleid nähe
ich bin sehr froh dass ich mein wissen
weitergeben kann
ich hörte eine große verantwortung für
den laden und die angestellten
denn für frauen ist es fast unmöglich
ein geschäft zu bekommen und zu führen
aber ein anfang fragten die männer was
wir hier eigentlich tun
ich war unsicher aber dann wusste ich
die antwort ich bin auch ein mensch ich
habe ein recht auf einen golf sie soll
mich in ruhe lassen
alexander genommen hat
ich habe den männern gesagt sie soll
nicht vor unserem laden sitzen und uns
kontrollieren
sie sagten sie seien wegen des schattens
dar aber ich habe sie weggeschickt
sollen sie an einem anderen ort schatten
suchen
wenn sie die gelegenheit bekommen bin
ich überzeugt dass frauen unabhängig
sein und dasselbe wie männer arbeiten
können
[Musik]
tipp du im nordwesten kolumbiens
nach den aufreibenden tagen im feld hat
abraham dobler endlich zeit für sich
dann steigen gedanken auf die im alltag
oft keinen platz haben abraham vermisst
seine familie und die freunde aus genf
wo er aufgewachsen ist
nein es ist nie ganz wie zuhause
ich vermisse das essen meiner mutter die
freunde die vertraute startet auch die
sicherheit ja es ist nirgends wie zu
hause
aber das spezielle am leben im ausland
ist das wenn man es auf gibt man oft
daran zurückdenkt auch an die schönen
momente mit gibt da wird mir das auch so
gehen
abraham ist 34 jährige träumt von einer
eigenen familie aber sein beruf verlangt
viel flexibilität und mobilität
das sind schwierige voraussetzungen
jemanden kennenlernen ist nicht das
problem
jemanden der mir in meiner arbeit folgen
möchte schon her
wir werden sehen was das leben für mich
bereithält
[Musik]
tel aviv seit über 60 jahren schwelt in
dieser gegend der israelisch arabischen
konflikt stefanie lr gönnt sich einen
ruhigen abend beim kochen kann sie sich
entspannen
aber die arbeit als delegierte die
palästinensische häftlinge in
israelischen gefängnissen besucht lässt
sie auch hier nicht los
denn draußen wird sie von beiden
konfliktparteien scharf beobachtet klar
die neutralität unparteilichkeit und
vertraulichkeit sind bei unseren
aktivitäten von existenzieller bedeutung
aber wir sind auch nur menschen
wir kommen nicht aus dem nichts wir
haben eine meinung zu den ereignissen
das soll auch so sein aber man muss
bewusst eine grenze ziehen zwischen dem
was man weiß und sagt alles was die
vertraulichkeit neutralität oder
unparteilichkeit verletzt darf man nicht
sagen
in diesem moment erreicht unseren
reporter eine besorgniserregende
nachricht ist der funny ich habe soeben
erfahren dass sechs seiner kollegen in
syrien entführt wurden
kalkar oder nationales rotes kreuz die
meldung lautet sechs mitarbeiter des ikk
wurden im nordwesten syriens entführt
das trifft mich ich habe einen
schweißausbruch kriege gänsehaut
hoffen wir dass sie ganz schnell
freikommen gesund und wohlbehalten in
solchen momenten sollte man nicht an das
schlimmste denken man muss ich sagen
dass sie bald frei sein werden
eigentlich kann man in jedem land in dem
das lka arbeitet entführt werden
dieses risiko ist teil des berufes wenn
man damit nicht umgehen kann wählt man
ihn auch nicht
bis vor kurzem hat sich stefanie auch
gewünscht als delegierte in syrien zu
arbeiten jetzt sollen sie nachdenklich
geworden
[Musik]
auch im ikk hauptquartier in genf ist
man angesichts der jüngsten ereignisse
alarmiert die sicherheit der delegierten
ist zwar das oberste gebot
aber alle risiken kann man nicht
ausschließen
der krisenstab arbeitet im red room
hinter verschlossenen türen
die geiselnahme ist auch im
präsidentenbüro thema peter maurer
bespricht mit seiner stabschefin die
neueste entwicklung immer weiter
natürlich erschüttere zieht die
rechnungs selber und aus präsident
probieren einfach irgendeine dialog sie
mit denen mit dem krisenstab und sorge
gibt es irgendwo nicht machen
die verhandlungen sind vertraulich das
leben der geiseln steht über allem
unsere fernsehkamera ist unerwünscht
[Musik]
auf diesen tag hat sich abraham plato
seit lange gefreut seine freunde aus
bogota besuchen ihn für ein ganzes
wochenende
zusammen haben sie ein musikfest
organisiert
durch
bei live musik und einem gemütlichen
essen wollen sie letzte details
besprechen aber raum ist vom besuch
begeistert auch fiona cook seine büro
kollegin kommt dazu
es ist das erste mal überhaupt dass mich
meine freunde besuchen seit ich hier im
einsatz bin für das ikk das ist
außerhalb der arbeit und ich kann dann
etwas anderes denken
[Musik]
aber dann reißt ein telefonanruf abraum
aus seiner fest lange einer
gewaltattacke fordert seine ganze
aufmerksamkeit
[Musik]
auch viewer ist sofort auf dem platz es
kam zu auseinandersetzungen zwischen
einer bewaffneten gruppe und
ordnungskräften
es gab offenbar keine zivilen opfer aber
ein polizist wurde verletzt
40 minuten von quito entfernt
er hat uns um hilfe gebeten aber es ist
schwierig etwas zu unternehmen so lange
die zusammenstöße anhalten
wir haben die sanität gerufen wir müssen
nun schauen was wir machen jetzt zählt
jede minute
wir brauchen dringend ein taxi niemand
holt diesen polizisten der schwer
verwundet ist wir versuchen dort
hinzugelangen sobald wir es geschafft
haben eine ambulanz und einen arzt zu
organisieren fahren wir dorthin
hast du eine ambulanz organisiert ok wo
treffen wir uns kommst du mit uns haben
wir einen arzt oder nicht
[Applaus]
genial aus angst vor den bewaffneten
gruppierungen will niemand den
verletzten polizisten den spital bringen
dessen leben scheint ernsthaft gefährdet
er hat zwei kugeln abgekriegt eine in
den kopf und eine in den rücken
ich denke er ist schwer verletzt ich
versuche die sicherheitskräfte zu
erreichen
die gegenseite zu kontaktieren ist
natürlich schwierig aber ich hoffe dass
wir das leben des verletzten retten
können
mal wieder
zurück im wohnhaus der delegation holt
abraham das ikk auto um so schnell als
möglich zu helfen
[Musik]
vor dem spital vernehmen er und fiona
die positive nachricht
die yamaha ist nicht selbst nicht genau
serena
uns wurde gesagt dass der zustand des
patienten stabil sei erlebt und ich bin
erleichtert dass er hier ist
er wurde von einem privaten taxi
hierhergebracht nur er mit dem fahrrad
das hat die dienststelle so entschieden
na ja er ist jetzt hier
schon morgen will abraham ins betroffene
auch fahren und sich ein eigenes bild
vom anschlag machen
[Musik]
wir sind in mexiko bei einem
männergefängnis im nordosten tel avivs
stefanie lr kontrolliert hier die
haftbedingungen von minderjährigen für
die junge frau eine nicht ganz einfache
aufgabe
rix ahnung wie man
es ist eine doch sehr männlich geprägte
umgebung
ich hab da einen kleinen trick den
ehering meiner großmutter ohne den gehe
ich nie ins gefängnis
das verhindert delikate situationen und
der status verheiratet verhilft einem
auch zu einem gewissen respekt in einem
solchen umfeld die gestrige entführung
der sechs kollegen beschäftigt das team
normalerweise kommen sie innerhalb von
stunden oder tagen frei wenn es länger
dauert kann es sehr sehr kompliziert
werden es ist verwirrend ist der
kidnapper allein in einigen meldungen
sprechen sie von einer person den
anderen von vier reuters berichtet von
bewaffneten männern
wir müssen mehr informationen abwarten
und das beste hoffen
dann kehrt der alltag zurück gefangenen
besucher machen die interviews
dokumentieren und bei mutmaßlichen
verstößen die regierung kontaktieren und
den fall ansprechen
aber erst müssen wir langwierige
sicherheitskontrollen absolvieren dann
endlich erhalten wir zugang zu den
gebäuden wo die interviews stattfinden
sollen wir das interview hier machen
und dann heißt es wieder sich in geduld
üben
[Musik]
wir sind in der ikrk delegation in goma
dieser geschwister haben ihre eltern in
kriegswirren verloren
heute bringt sie das ek nach hause wie
habt ihr euch verloren im krieg 2006
sich wieder zu finden war also sehr
schwierig ja und wertet die heute wieder
sehen unseren vater sechs jahren um
zogen die fünf kinder durch die wälder
ganz auf sich allein gestellt wir
mussten unser dorf verlassen
dann wurden wir angegriffen wir wurden
auseinandergerissen
so haben wir mutter und vater verloren
aber jetzt haben wir unseren vater
wieder musik er war zu fünft und ihr
habt euch nie verloren nein gut hast du
sie zusammengehalten ja
in diesem land das so groß ist wie ganz
westeuropa werden familien oft über
hunderte und tausende von kilometern
auseinander gerissen
der etat palombo organisiert mehrere
zusammenführungen pro jahr
[Applaus]
jedes kind hat seine eigene geschichte
normalerweise beginnen wir mit der suche
anhand der adressen die uns die kinder
angeben
die sind zwar meistens veraltet aber
häufig wissen nachbarn wohin die familie
gezogen sind dann recherchieren wir
weiter bis wir die aktuelle adresse
haben
[Musik]
eine ganze generation ist hier mit dem
krieg aufgewachsen
er hat überall seine spuren hinterlassen
in dieser junge mann wurde vor sechs
monaten verhaftet nach einer odyssee
durch verschiedene gefängnisse wird er
jetzt zu seiner familie zurückgebracht
wir fahren durch koma eine stadt die vom
krieg gezeichnet ist
zusätzlich hat vor zwölf jahren ein
vulkanausbruch alles mit lava und asche
bedeckt eine halbe million menschen
mussten fliehen
eine katastrophe mehr in dieser
krisengeschüttelten gegend
dann erreichen wir sein heimatdorf
auch hier hat der lavastrom die erde in
eine apokalyptische landschaft
verwandelt
[Musik]
vor einer knappen woche schossen
rebellen der m23 granaten bis hierher
[Applaus]
die nachricht über die rückkehr des
verlorenen sohnes breitet sich im
quartier wie ein lauffeuer aus sechs
monate lang hat die familie nichts mehr
von ihm gehört
[Musik]
schließlich taucht der vater auf etwas
schüchtern
die mutter ist noch auf dem feld jedes
mal reagieren die eltern wieder anders
vor allem die afrikaner sind sehr
diskret mit ihren emotionen bei manchen
wiedervereinigungen hatte man das gefühl
die eltern freuen sich gar nicht aber
dann entdeckt man sie weinend irgendwo
im versteckten
es ist immer sehr bewegend weil die
mutter nicht da ist sorgt die tante für
stimmen aus dem jungen mann sichtlich
peinlich ist
[Applaus]
versprengte kinder zu ihren familien
zurück zu bringen
das ist für mich unbezahlbar gibt nichts
vergleichbares
ich habe in meinem leben schon viel
gemacht aber das hier ist die bereiche
installation die familie bekommt einen
vorrat an getreide bohnen und zucker
schließlich gilt es einen bauch mehr
satt zu kriegen
trotz der schwierigen umstände der junge
hat einen traum
ich würde gerne etwas lernen was
möchtest du werden was ist ein ziel ich
möchte schon für werden oder
ladenbesitzer
[Applaus]
die kinder tanzen mit rita zur musik aus
dem autoradio ein kurzer augenblick des
glücks auch für die delegierten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in kolumbien ist abraham duplo mit
seinem team unterwegs zum dorf in dem
gestern ein polizist schwer verletzt
wurde
die situation bereitet ihm sorgen
wir sind auf der verbindungsstraße von
quito nach medellin
die gegend ist umkämpft es hat
bewaffnete gruppierungen und das ist der
zweite anschlag auf eine polizeiwache
innerhalb von drei monaten ein
rebellengebiet zu passieren heißt
wachsam zu sein
nach der ankunft im dorf schildert ein
polizeileutnant abraham die ereignisse
immer wieder kommt es zu gezielten
anschlägen auf institutionen der
ordnungshüter
denn die anwesenheit der polizei ist in
bewaffneten gruppierungen ein dorn im
auge
der polizeiposten gleicht einer festung
es ist nicht nur geschossen worden auch
eine granate kam zum einsatz
[Musik]
hier haben späteren geschlagen
im dach
um dem fenster wem gehört das aus es
steht leer
es ist leer von hier aus hat er die
granate geworfen in richtung des
polizisten der wahrscheinlich dort
drüben stand wenigstens gab es keine
zivilen opfer
es passierten 8 aber es gibt viele
wohnhäuser in der nähe
einige sind bereits zerstört worden die
situation hier ist ziemlich beunruhigend
auch der priester des dorfes sorgt sich
um die sicherheit seiner gemeinde
immer wieder geraten dorfbewohner
zwischen die fronten denn die
bevölkerung mit hineingezogen wird wäre
es wichtig darüber nachzudenken ob der
polizeiposten mitten im dorf am
richtigen ort ist das müssen wir
diskutieren und schauen ob es eine
alternative gibt
das ikrk vermittelt hier seit über 40
jahren
die fronten sind verhärtet zivilisten
sind die hauptleidtragenden
es ist manchmal schon frustrierend wenn
sich nichts ändert
aber es ist nicht die hauptaufgabe des
ikk dinge zu verändern
wir sind hier und das leid der
zivilbevölkerung zu lindern
sie sind die eigentlichen opfer des
konflikts
[Musik]
auch die fronten zwischen israeli und
palästinensern sind seit vielen
jahrzehnten verhärtet wieder sind wir im
aikido
ist der fall er überprüft hier die
haftbedingungen von minderjährigen
dieser gefangenen ist 14 jährig
also ich heiße stefanie ich bin
delegierte des internationalen komitee
vom roten kreuz
kennst du uns weißt du wieso hier bin 9
km
keine ahnung ich möchte wissen wie du
hier lebst
[Musik]
in diesem moment werden wir aufgefordert
die kamera abzustellen
trotz drehbewegung wir müssen draußen
warten
[Musik]
in medow sitzen etwa 900 menschen ein
neben gewöhnlichen delinquenten vor
allem politischer gefangener
ihnen werden vornehmlich terroristische
aktivitäten vorgeworfen
[Musik]
die gespräche mit den befangenen sind
streng vertraulich ist er verliert auf
uns keine details schildern
so kann das e krk sicherstellen dass sie
hier auch künftig zugang haben
und der ist wichtig so ist der kontakt
zu den gefangenen sichergestellt und
eine minimale kontrolle von seiten des
ikk kann stattfinden
[Musik]
es gibt anschuldigungen
was macht man nun damit manchmal hilft
es einfach nur dass der minderjährige
mit jemandem darüber sprechen kann den
die sache berührt jemand der sich darum
kümmert und versucht etwas zu
unternehmen auch wenn er weiß die
resultate sind bisweilen mir schwierig
messbar aber so ist das eben dann
überraschend die gute nachricht sie
wurden freigelassen sind gesund und
wohlauf
drei krk kolleg nun an freiwillige
wurden gesund und wohlbehalten
freigelassen erwarten mehr informationen
bezüglich den drei anderen kollegen
das klingt schon mal sehr gut
dann geht es zurück nach tel aviv wo
viel administration auf sie wartet nach
dem vorfall mit dem verletzten
polizisten ist abraham zurück bei seinen
freunden
sie besprechen die letzten details für
das musikfestival vom abend wollen wir
eine gute zeit haben mit freunden und
menschen die ich gerne habe und die
nicht häufig hier sind wir wollen für
eine kinder organisation sammeln und
versuchen den konflikt für einen abend
zu vergessen
[Musik]
in der nächsten folge macht abraham
kladow einem erste-hilfe-kurs mitten im
dschungel
[Musik]
in genf wird die fahne gehisst und der
rote teppich ausgerollt
präsident maurer empfängt hohen besuch
stéphanie er erlebt den alltag junger
palästinenser im westjordanland
putin zeigt uns seine heimat und
schwelgt in erinnerungen aus der
kindheit
[Musik]